a day after Venezuela's authorities said
voters had overwhelmingly approved the
Takeover of an oil Rich region in
neighboring Guana a Victorious president
Nicolas Maduro vowed to abide by the
will of the people and attacked those he
said were trying to undermine the
results to the right Wingers who support
Exxon Mobile the financed right wing
that supports the rights of Guyana and
not those of Venezuela I tell them we
are moving forward this referendum is
binding and I will comply with the
Mandate of the people the people's voice
is sacred the voice of the people is the
voice of
God Venezuelan election authorities said
95% of the 10.5 million votes they have
counted were in favor of creating a new
Venezuelan state in the
eso a densely forested region the
Venezuela says was stolen when the
Border was drawn more than a century ago
but some Venezuelans remain SC skeptical
everything they said is a lie because I
passed by several polling centers and
everything was always empty I don't know
where they got that number of people who
supposedly voted for the
eso the government promoted the
referendum for weeks calling it an act
of patriotism and using it as a way to
gauge maduro's support ahead of next
year's presidential
election Venezuela's long claimed the
area but tensions only increased after
large deposits of oil were found in
2015 on Monday the US state department
said his supported and negotiated
settlement we support a peaceful
resolution of the Border dispute between
Venezuela and Guyana U the 1899 award
determined the land boundary between
Venezuela and Guyana should be respected
unless or until the parties come to a
new agreement or a competent legal body
decides otherwise this is not something
that will be settled by settled by a
referendum it's unclear what steps the
Venezuelan government will take to
follow through on the result but any
action is likely to be met with
International condemnation in the
meantime maduro's rhetoric is keeping
Guyana on edge Alexandra Al jazer